[MUSIC PLAYING]
So if you'll recall from our
last lesson, we had created a
method that set up all of the
appropriate properties with
our GPP sign in object and
created all the appropriate
delegate methods, but we hadn't
actually called the
method that sets anything up
or, for that matter, done
anything to sign the user in.
So let's do that now.
We're going to go back into
our code, and let's add a
viewDidLoad method.
And we'll say Super viewDidLoad,
and then we can
initialize this GPP
sign in object.
And then we can take this
shared instance and call
authenticate.
And this is basically the call
that tells our sign in object,
OK, now let's attempt
to sign in the user.
So let's try this now.
See what happens.
Hey, look at that.
We're set right into
our OAuth dialog.
Now before I go on, let's take
a look at this URL here.
I'm going to Select All.
Of course, it turns out this
doesn't actually Select All.
Let's go from here.
All right, now I'm going
to copy this.
And let's open up a random
text file here,
and paste this in.
And we get this giant URL.
But let's break this up by the
URL arguments, and take a look
at this thing.
Does this look kind of
familiar to you?
This URL looks pretty similar
to the one we had in our
presentation.
Remember this one?
We went to accounts.google.com,
we set
the client ID, we set
the scope, and we
set a redirect URI.
Well, now let's go back
and look at our URL.
And you can see here we have a
scope, we have a client ID,
and we have a redirect URI.
There's a few other things
that we've added here.
This response type code means
give me back a one time code.
This line basically specifies
the user's language.
This state variable is
used to help deter
cross-site forgery requests.
And this GP SDK basically just
says that the request came
from the Google+ SDK
version 1.3.
But look at that.
This giant URL, you'll pretty
much know what's going on.
We're saying, hey, Google,
here's our client ID.
This is our "Guess My
Number" application.
We're asking for the
Auth/gamescope.
And when you're done, send it
back to com.google.Guess
MyNumber:/oauth2callback.
Look at that.
We're now able to make sense
of this giant URL.
So now let's go back
to our simulator
here and scroll down.
And I'm going to click Accept.
Now at this point, it redirects
back to our
application, which
is good, right?
Because that's what we specified
in our redirect URI,
go to com.google.GuessMyNumber.
However, if we were to take a
look at our console output in
Xcode, we don't see anything.
We didn't get to this finish
with auth error handler.
And the question is, why not?
Well, that's because while
mobile Safari does correctly
redirect back to our
application, our application
does nothing to handle
that URL.
It just kind of gets sent
to us and we ignore it.
So we need to do something
about that.
And this is something we do
within our App Delegate.
So go over to your App Delegate,
and let's import
Google+/Google+.h.
And we're going to add
another method here.
We're going to add application
open URL source application
annotation.
This is basically the method
that gets called when your
application receives some sort
of URL and is asked by the
system, hey, can you
handle this?
It returns yes if it's able to
properly handle it and returns
no if it says, I don't
really know what to
do with this thing.
Now it turns out this method is
pretty simple because the
Google+ library includes its own
method that does most of
the heavy lifting for you.
So first, just in case actually
you're curious, let's
add in a little NS
log that shows
the URL that we received.
So I have received the
URL to handle.
We can call URL absoluteString.
And then we're just going
to call the class method
GPPURLHandler handleURL source
application annotation.
So the URL here is URL.
Source application is
source application.
And annotation is annotation.
So we put this into
conditional.
We're basically checking with
Google+ and saying, hey, does
this look like a URL
you can handle?
If it does, we return yes.
Otherwise, we'll return no.
In case you're saying
to yourself, hey,
that's extra code.
Why not just say return this?
The answer is that this might
work if the only URL you are
ever going to check against
is one sent from Google+.
But in reality, there
might be URLs you're
going to want to handle.
So more likely than not, there
might be another elsif here
and another elsif and so on
before you finally return no.
So that's why we wrote
it that way.
So now we can run this, and
let's see what happens.
Again, we're taken to the "Guess
My Number" application.
I click Accept.
We get redirected back
to our application.
And look here, we've got
a whole bunch of OAuth
information here in our log.
You can see the URL
we received.
And this code equals blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
This is our one time use code
that the system received.
It then exchanged that
for a bearer token.
And since everything worked as
planned, our GPP sign in
object called finished
with auth error.
And in this case, our Auth is
a GTM OAuth2 authentication
object that includes an access
token, a refresh token, and
our one time use code along
with an expiration date.
And our error here is null
because we ran into no errors.
So look at that.
We received our bearer token
from the system, and we've
successfully signed
the user in.
Of course, it turns out I still
kind of lied to you.
We signed the user in, but
we just did it by calling
authorized during viewDidLoad.
This isn't the greatest
user experience.
You don't want your player
taken to an OAuth2 dialog
before he or she has even had
a chance to see your game's
title screen.
So we really are going to add
a sign in button to initiate
the sign in process.
And really, honest this time,
we're going to add it in the
next lesson.
Have I ever lied
to you before?
So stick with me.
Sign in button's coming next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]